this story came up a couple of days ago
and
it horrified me you know that I'm not
much of a dog person
I'm not a cat person either but I'm not
I'm not really a dog person I'm a I'm a
people person
and this is so sad there's a restaurant
in San Francisco
that is now serving dogs filet mignon
in what is considered to be the first
Eatery designed only for dogs
this is not like you go to the cafe and
they have a little puppy bowl of water
and treats or whatever this is the
restaurant is only for dogs
it's called Doge d-o-g-u-e like Vogue
dog
and it launched in September in the
Mission District in San Francisco
and the meals include
several courses and they cost 75 dollars
per dog
I kid you not
costs more money to feed a dog at this
restaurant
then most people pay even at a nice
restaurant to go out and eat themselves
it does include a mimosa and a pastry
for the dog's owner but the real food is
for the dogs
the dog plates have items such as
chicken skin waffles filet mignon stick
tartar with quail egg oh that sounds
nice
and uh
some of the food you know is relatively
affordable it can get up to 95 dollars
why why is this happening
it's happening for one reason and one
reason only
it's because people are not having
children
and so they are treating their dogs as
their children
I'm not opposed to dogs I don't really
like them and I don't intend to get one
but I'm not opposed to dogs they're fine
in theory I like them in theory
but I really don't like dogs when the
dogs are treated like children
and and that's what has happened in our
society
people
don't want to they think that they don't
want to have kids because they think
it's too much responsibility
and they think it's too expensive and
they think they're not in a state in
life where they can then they'd have to
make the commitment to get married
ideally and you know it's just too much
responsibility and commitment man I'm
just going to start out I'm just going
to get a dog
it's the same thinking that as people
say I don't want to get married right
away maybe I'll just move in with my
girlfriend you know just kind of it's a
lesser step I can get out whenever I
want less responsibility you can't you
know take a you can't take a kid to the
shelter you're not really supposed to
you can't take a dog to the shelter if
it's too much so
I'm going to do that and that'll be a
lot easier but the the
practical effect of that
is you don't have less responsibility
really people treat their dogs like
children they spend every bit of time
that they would spend on children they
just Channel all that time toward their
dogs I know people who get babysitters
for their dogs to come over for their
homes when they go away and sit with the
dog for days on end and spend all sorts
of money on the dog's vet and The
Grooming and the food and the filet
mignon and everything okay
and this is what they think about
cohabitation they say well I'm just
going to move in but then it's not as
much of a commitment it's not going to
be as intense as getting married but it
is just as intense you know you are
living with this person you you're
you're very often putting the same
amount of energy and emotional
investment and money even into that
you're just not getting the fruits of it
so you're putting all the same amount of
money and and time and Care into your
dog but you the dog's not going to take
care of you in your old age you're not
going to see your smile reflected on the
face of the dog
you're you're not going to get little
doggy grandchildren someday you're not
going to get to go to your doggies
ballet recital
you're not and even now it's really sad
people will take their dogs to Doggy
Daycare and they'll get little
certificates for your doggy completed
this task or your doggy jumped through
the hoop today and they so you you just
can't deny your human longings and so
what people are doing is they're not
avoiding that emotional and financial
expenditure they're just putting it in a
in a dead end place
same thing with with cohabitation you're
not avoiding the financial and emotional
expenditure you're just putting it into
a place where there's much less
stability where the whole thing could
fall apart where it's not designed to
grow and grow your family and grow your
life and people just
people just need to grow up and save the
filet mignon for the adult Save The
Flaming yawn and the quail eggs for me
okay because I can appreciate it much
more than a dog
and stop usually you're not you're not
going to avoid
you're not going to avoid
civilization and Society you're not
going to avoid
the way that that life has been lived
for Millennia okay we think that we in
the Modern Age we think that everything
that came before us was really dumb and
stupid and we figured it out sometime in
the mid 1960s we figured it out that all
the people that came before us were dumb
idiots and they were totally wrong and
we've reinvented the wheel and we're
just so smart
and we can avoid all of the Eternal
questions and natural longings of human
beings and it's not true
it's not true and the more we deviate
from the wisdom of the ages and the more
we we Channel our our desires into
bizarre places the less fulfilled we're
going to be
stop it give your dog a bone and you eat
the filet mignon
now rhymes now I don't know very much
about polling so I'm going to invite on
a master pollster Robert kehale to tell
me what I should know going into midterm
elections the rest of the show is
continuing now
you don't want to miss it if you're not
a member click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
oh
foreign